as you'll be aware Jeremy Corbyn has
asked the leaders of other political
parties to install him as caretaker
Prime Minister until the general
election in order to prevent a No Deal
brexit under Boris Johnson it's a plan
that was met with a lukewarm response
the Lib Dem leader Joe Swinson arguing
mr. Corbyn is not the right man for the
job
the Laura peacock is Shadow Minister for
labour John's whanau from Lancaster in
County Durham very good morning to you
and so mr corbyn's plans now blown out
of the water do you think no I don't
think so I think it's constitutionally
right that the leader of the Opposition
with 247 MPs other parties are smaller
they have their electoral mandate but of
course it pales in significance to the
leader of the Opposition I think that
Jeremy behind the scenes is talking to
all opposition leaders to first and
foremost prevent a No Deal brexit and
you know kind of the Liberal Democrats
saying so clearly that they wouldn't
entertain this I think we have urged
them to change their mind because
they've said all along that they don't
want a No Deal brexit well the best way
to do that is to get behind Jeremy
Corbyn and you're someone who was quite
famously in the past said you couldn't
even be friends with the tour it hardly
seems the right attitude if you're
trying to build a government of national
unity I didn't say that sir said I
didn't go to Westminster to fraternize
to be friends to have drinks with Tory
MPs those people who are creating havoc
upon my community I've done surgery
after surgery after surgery this weekend
where I see the toll that has been taken
on my community not only on the high
streets which I think we'll talk about
later but individually people suffering
I never ever said that that's you know
huge slippage and I have always been
collegiate and Jeremy Corbyn has always
been collegiate and trying to bet get
the best for my constituency trying to
get the best for the country and so you
know jeremy has has you know held out
the hand of compromise many many times
to try and a catastrophe of an ordeal
brexit it's time that the other
political parties and some have said
that there will be more than
to do that but it's time for the Liberal
Democrats instead of enabling an audio
brexit which is essentially what they'll
do is to rally behind Jeremy Corbyn to
stop what could be economic catastrophe
in in terms and if you're saying the
determination here is to act in the best
interest of the country would you then
support a government of national unity
where Jeremy Corbyn was not the
caretaker Prime Minister and perhaps
someone like Kenneth Clarke was I think
constitutionally it is right Jeremy
Corbyn is the leader of the Opposition
it's the largest party that isn't in
government he should lead those
conversations and you know he carries
with him the largest amount of MPs and
quite frankly I think it's arrogant of
you know say the Liberal Democrats or
other people who don't have such a
mandate in Parliament remember Jeremy
Corbyn was sent to as the leader of the
Labour Party was elected twice but also
had 40% of the vote so at the last
election I think it's quite strange if
I'm honest that were considering other
options constitutionally that is the
right thing to do but let's consider the
inverse if Jeremy wasn't doing this if
he wasn't trying to reach out across all
sides of the House of Commons what would
people say you know here's absolutely
doing the right thing to avert this No
Deal brags that that we have said in our
manifesto that we have said time and
time again in the House of Commons that
other political parties have committed
to the only way to do that is to get
behind Jeremy Corbyn so that he can have
this time limited period as a as a
caretaker Prime Minister to avert a no
deal brexit it's very simple it's it's a
fair point to ask though isn't it if
you're so determined to stop a No Deal
breaks in why didn't the Labour Party
back to resumes deal which was in effect
a fairly soft brexit well you know even
the hardest line Greg the tears didn't
back the deal the hardest line remain as
they don't [ __ ] the deal you know the
deal was you know insufficient due to
our six Tests it it was a blind brexit
if you like we couldn't we couldn't have
signed up to that there was no way we
could have signed up to that and as you
know most
the House of Commons most of the members
of parliament could not sign up to that
and so we have said all along
our priority is about averting and
nerdier brexit the moral and political
imperative when we go back to Parliament
is to make sure that happens
and you know to plea or all of the
members of the House of Commons that
they put the interests of the nation
above you no worries about their own
electability you know you see the
independent MPs probably don't want a
general election because they're worried
about their suits the Liberal Democrats
are potentially worried about the hype
in terms of their resurgence that maybe
doesn't exist at next election that to
put those selfish interests above the
interests of the nation would be it
would be deeply selfish or political and
I'll say again and our moral imperative
is to stop an ER deal brags that you saw
some of the leaked operation
yellowhammer projections on about
catastrophes and/or scare mongering they
are saying in reality these are the
things that could happen if No Deal was
enabled Boris Johnson is willing to
allow that to happen because he is
completely shielded and the people that
he represents are completely shielded
from the effects of a new deal brexit I
spoke to factories in my constituency on
Friday who said please whatever you do
can you try and stop a new deal brexit
because it's uncertain from the
manufacturers to the shop assistants on
on on the four courts who are saying we
need we need some certainty and Jeremy
Corbyn is the person in my view and in
many people's view who will bring that
certainty as a caretaker Prime Minister
well in terms of getting some sort of
Economic Security back in this country
and as you said there's a whichever way
there is undoubtedly a certain amount of
uncertainty at the moment and oh you you
are keen you have come up with a an idea
to revive Britain's high streets how
would that work so I think that you know
not too far away from here we have
concert high street and there are many
vacant properties this is about we are
announcing that we are going to give
power to councils to take properties
that have been left vacant for 12 months
into management essentially I say that
you know new startup businesses
charities non not profit
organizations could use those vacant
those vacant properties and for
somewhere like concert that I represent
that would be absolutely brilliant
because we're in a bit of a negative
cycle at the moment and yes it is about
more than empty properties I know that
it's about business rates it's about how
much people are paid it's about consumer
confidence but one of the effects of a
negative cycle of walking down that high
street and seeing the empty properties
is that people don't want to invest or
don't have the confidence to invest or
you know you could have some money to
give the area a bit of a facelift but
are you gonna do that when you don't
have people invest in or sitting in
those properties so this is about saying
if you if you are leaving that property
empty for 12 months then we're going to
use it we're going to offer it out to
people who can use it and contribute to
a positive cycle for those retail spaces
and I think that and again I'll met I'll
mention concept but you know that the
buildings are are relatively cheap for
people to buy but they're buying as an
investment opportunity well that does
nothing for my community for them and
just sit vacant and for the next few
years it it really makes a place feel
and tired it makes it feel depressed and
we want to open those spaces up
reinvigorate them but as I said you know
I'm aware that this intersects with my
department a Shadow Minister for labour
and government I would be Minister for
labour where we would give the country
an immediate paly pay rise sorry and we
know that working people spend in their
local areas they don't harvest money in
you know in their bank accounts this
they spend on their local high streets
forgive me consumer confidence but
forgive me for interrupting but but just
very quickly visit there's a hard
reality here is that know that you're
saying people will spend the money on
the high street well the reality is
they're not spending on the high street
they're spending on online shopping
because it tends to be quicker tends to
be more convenient and crucially tends
to be cheaper and I think that we have
to recognize that then what the high
street can offer has to be different to
what what we thought of a high street
could offer in the past I'm not saying
that this has to be you know just
replicate anything
that we've had in the past this is about
making the High Street a place where
people can socialize where people can go
and talk to people where people can you
know see interesting things if spaces
are opened up to community groups if
there are bespoke pop-up shops that are
allowed you know we have some
unbelievable produce in we're deal and
it's about connecting we're deal with
concert high street that shouldn't be
too hard but are people gonna come are
people going to invest if there's lots
of things in in there waste of this car
parking charges if there isn't enough
car parking spaces if there are lots of
empty empty spaces fundamentally if
people don't have the money to spend you
know that is you know it's a major
factor and people are feeling that the
the squeeze of nearly ten years of
austerity so if you if your pay isn't
really any better in relative terms and
it was ten years ago you do look for the
cheapest products online I'm not going
to make a judgement about that but but
once we give people a pay rise once
people have that public sector pickup
lifted once people enjoy more security
because they have day1 rights at work or
or much more secure contracts along side
you know other services being able to
use the high streets because they've
been given that opportunity through
their local council you can see that it
just becomes a much more positive space
okay Laura pig got good to talk to you
today thank you thank you